anyone who lives alone and manifests no
longing to be in a relationship is in
our times almost automatically more or
less secretly viewed as both pitiable
and deeply troubled it's simply not for
possible to be at once alone and normal
this sets us up for collective
catastrophe because it means that a huge
number of people who have no innate wish
to live with anyone else and are at
heart deeply ill suited to doing so are
every year press-ganged and shamed into
conjugal life with disastrous results
for all involved
only once singlehood is completely equal
prestige with its alternative can we
ensure that people will be free in their
choices and hence join couples for the
right reasons because they love another
person rather than because they're
terrified of remaining single here then
are a few of the many good reasons to
spend your life alone because romantic
love is a dangerous illusion we should
recognize that romantic love the idea of
being deeply enamored of one special
partner of a whole lifetime is a very
new ambitious and really pretty odd
concept at best 250 years old from close
up over long periods of time almost
everyone is condemned to be pretty
dispiriting and difficult a good
romantic marriage is evidently
theoretically possible but it's also
extremely unlikely in practice which
would make any failure feel a good deal
less shameful no one thinks that partner
is terrific after a while those among us
who choose to stay single shouldn't be
thought unromantic indeed we may be
among the very most romantic of all
because it is in the end the fervent
romantics who should be especially
careful of ending up in mediocre
relationships relationships best suit
the kind of people who don't actually
expect too much from them we aren't sane
enough to be in relationships though
it's a sign of some maturity to know how
to love and live alongside someone it is
actually a sign of even greater maturity
to recognize that this is something one
isn't
in the end going to be psychologically
capable of as a good portion of us there
simply are not retiring oneself
voluntarily in order to save others and
oneself from the consequences of one's
own inner emotional turmoil is the true
sign of a great and kind soul being
alone means not inflicting yourself on
others it spares you from constant
reminders of how difficult and strange
you are no one is there to hold a mirror
up record your antics and constantly
make you accountable for them if you're
lucky you'll be able to tolerate and
even like yourself if you're on your own
relationships spoil love it may be
better to feel alone and be denied sex
outside of a relationship than inside
one one thing the single are never
denied is hope well this isn't to say
that being alone is without problems
there are of course drawbacks to both
states being single and being in a
couple loneliness in the one suffocation
anger and frustration in the other the
truth is we're simply not terribly good
at being happy whatever our relationship
status which is ultimately an argument
for neither rushing too fast into a
couple or rushing too fast out of one
you